boss secrets often the window you go and
why is McDonald's still counting this is
really insecure isn't it
forty jillion 80 million zillion billion
Killian tell you what is this does it
mean anything to anyone 89 billion sold
okay I'll have one I would love to meet
the chairman of the board of McDonald's
just say to him look we all get it
you've sold a lot of hamburgers whatever
the hell the number is just put up a
sign McDonald's we're doing very well I
don't need to hear about every goddamn
one of them well what is their ultimate
goal to have cows just surrendering
voluntarily or something
showing up at the door we'd like to turn
ourselves in we see the sign we realized
we have very little chance out there
so we're going on the highway we've been
on the road for like three hours and in
the distance we see a McDonald's we see
the golden arches and we got so excited
we started chanting McDonald's
McDonald's McDonald's McDonald's and my
dad pulled into the drive-thru and we
started cheering and then he ordered one
black coffee for himself
and kept driving
and you know as mad as that made me as a
little kid in retrospect that is the
funniest thing I have ever seen in my
entire life how perfect is that he had a
van
little kid and he got black coffee the
one thing from McDonald's no child could
enjoy got to be a good cook
I didn't realize my mother was a good
cook too after I moved out the house
when you're a child of your mother I'm
taking a McDonald's you don't think she
can cook and I had one of those mothers
you know no matter what she wants she
has the ingredients at home you say mom
stop get some it Donna she go I got
hamburger meat at home but I want
McDonald's hamburger I'll make you a
hamburger better than McDonald's we're
better in McDonald's that's right when
you get home you can help mama make it
you say [ __ ] that rip that better than
McDonald's
you must say okay go eat me at the big
black frying pan from under stove so
you're handing a big black frying pan
but you say now why you in there I want
you going refrigerator give me the chop
meat and why you're gonna get me a green
pepper and onion and you said ain't no
green peppers and McDonald's I'm not
making me guys I'm making your mama's
burger I need a green pepper the onion
why you in there give me a egg out -
what's your name is phone I want
hamburgers you make a mean muffins
I'm not making an Egg McMuffin I don't
even know no damn ignorant is just give
me the egg I'll just shut your mouth as
you take the egg and the green peppers
and chop the green pepper up in big
chunks don't even dice it big chunks of
green peppers and onion and mix the egg
in and put paprika and all this [ __ ] in
and make a big meatball and put in the
Millers frying pan and McDonald's no
meat is this thing your mother's [ __ ] is
like this is fatter green peppers
hanging out of it and [ __ ] and it's a
big split in the middle and grease is
popping out and you're looking at it
while it's popping looking at the grease
in the pan you think of yourself I don't
look like no McDonald's he must say go
inside the fridge right and give me a
gift go inside and get me the bread out
the breadbox and you go look in the
breadbox you say my oh we don't have no
hamburger buns oh we have this one to
bed that's what I said get the bread out
the bread box you're gonna put on grab
Wonder Bread goddamn it British bridge
better bring me that Biff I'll slap you
in your mouth comes on Wonder Bread much
is that bread cause and tell me some
[ __ ] about Wonder Bread this is Wonder
bit of hamburgers a ham burger as you
make it and put it in the middle of
scrag Wonder Bread and McDonald's they
use buns the meat calvess all bread and
your mother's the meats right in the
middle of the bread with grease running
through the middle making the bread
stick to the plate now it's big green
peppers hanging out the top of these big
meatball on the bread and you try to put
some ketchup on it and the mixed with
the grease turn the bread into pink
dough then you grab it and get
fingerprinted and you got big pink
fingerprints in the dough and you stand
there looking at it and you try to make
it look like McDonald's so you rip the
edges off around and make it round and
you got green peppers and grease running
down your hand a mostly now go on
outside and play and other kids got
McDonald's they are psycho way god
[Applause]
dunno I got a gun no you standing there
with this big house burger it kids the
opposite yeah well you get that big
welfare green pepper burger
are you cried my mother made a long slob
a little kids cry some long slob come
out their mouth and hang is this far to
the ground and it won't break and adults
stand around going that's not gonna
break and it won't the wind can blow
that slop you know what you can see kids
crying I'd do it all the time sadistic
I'd like to go to the supermarket and
watch mothers lose it and beat the [ __ ]
out there you go into McDonald's you
might go in there later on you might
need to poo
have you noticed how underneath
McDonald's it still says restaurant
who's that for who doesn't know what
McDonald's do and also restaurant is it
a restaurant really you guys are a
couple right how long you been together
year in a bit okay so long-term
relationship you're in a bit you being
together how annoyed would you be madam
on a scale between one and [ __ ] very
if next Valentine's he said to you yeah
booked a restaurant yeah
yeah I spoke to the maitre d yeah Ronald
I think his name was he was either the
maitre d or a five-star general because
he had the whole bear
I've organized the table for two and he
recommends the filly over there you'd
[ __ ] kill him will you
if you doesn't know what McDonald's do
at this stage you'd have to be living
underground for 25 [ __ ] years
the sisters
hamburger schnitzel
schnitzel for a fritter
I've got stocked outside of McDonald's
this guy said to me the other day he
said this cheap food he's only made
possible by GM farming cruelty to
animals in the exploitation of workers
in the third world i said i hold up
you had me a cheap food i'm coming in
there's no need for the hard sell all
the other stuff is just a bonus last
month an 80 year old Albuquerque woman
was awarded over two million dollars in
damages from McDonald's after she
spilled some of their coffee in her lap
and suffered severe burns as a result
McDonald's this week has put a warning
label on its coffee cups they're read
caution do you think you're gonna manage
to avoid pouring it directly on your
crotch this time use senile old hag
think you can manage that tab now you
know what it's just the ramblings of
someone who's sliding in to the back
nine of his life and I'm not
understanding half the [ __ ] that's going
on you know but you know what the big
things that really made me feel old was
when McDonald's started making salads
that literally ripped my heart out I'm
like doing what look now they have wraps
and they're doing all of this [ __ ] you
know what it was was I shape people
complain to him that you you know ever
need healthy options it's like this is
McDonald's this [ __ ] is poison who the
[ __ ] comes here to get in shape
whenever I get McDonald's I have a whole
plant at my age I'm 48 years old I know
what I'm gonna order I'm gonna go in
there it's gonna taste great 20 minutes
later I'm gonna want to kill myself and
then I'm gonna go to the gym tomorrow
I'm going to the gym tomorrow and no
matter how much I say that I woke up the
demon in me I woke up the demon and all
that grease is just coursing through my
veins and no matter how much I want to
go to the gym there's gonna be this
other voice going do get an Egg McMuffin
go down there and get an Egg McMuffin
I'm gonna sit up like The Manchurian
Candidate okay we're going to McDonald's
is Mike in shape voices in the
background
[Music]
gonna drive right down right I know what
it is but somehow out of shape people
somehow got that made them that they're
too [ __ ] blame they had to have more
healthy [ __ ] cuz they're the reason why
everybody's fat how come they have to do
what about Ben and Jerry's how come they
don't put a little kale in their ice
cream why is that
Oh cuz you're a couple a hippies man
you're like making ice cream they're
going after big bad McDonald's you know
if it's just who the [ __ ] goes
McDonald's to get its shape don't give
me that horseshit that eating healthy is
expensive it isn't go to [ __ ]
supermarket this throwing the vegetables
at you this celery get it the [ __ ] out
of here 70 cents 25 cents for a banana
whatever the [ __ ] you want get it out of
here before it goes bad no it's [ __ ]
up they somehow convinced them that that
you know McDonald's is the reason why
I'm out of shape
I would have got a salad but you didn't
have the option Sol's way well I guess I
gotta get 52 Big Macs
thanks a lot McDonald's it's like dude
you're an adult it's not their job to
babysit you they're a [ __ ] business if
you order 50 sandwiches they're gonna
give it to you it's your job to not do
it you [ __ ] dope right
oh sorry I know
yeah dude McDonald's McDonald's exists
for two reasons okay it's for drunk
people and it's for children all right
that's what this thing is you know
you're in your car your kids won't shut
the hell up you go to the drive-thru you
go to the drive-thru you get a couple of
poisoned burgers you throw it down their
throats they're little systems can't
handle it they start
it's not not not and you're upfront
you're bigger you can handle a bigger
dose of poison you know to me pop in
your death leopard cassette you have a
little moment for yourself